jouer à tous les auditeurs permettait
tout de même que je puisse saluer
l'immense mickey présenter mes voeux à
l'ensemble des martiniquais en
particulier les ppr et les ppr tout ce
que je n'ai pas encore vu des voeux de
santé de bonheur même si les temps
paraissent difficiles vous êtes maire du
morne-rouge 10e mère est la première
femme à ce poste pour cette paroisse
devenue commune en 1889 130 ans
d'existence
on en reparlera mais puisque vous êtes
venus nous voir pour cela mais il ya
également cette actualité dans cette
actualité là lettre d' emmanuel macron
français pour lancer ce grand débat
national êtes vous déjà madame d'ulysse
petit elle vous déjà convaincu par la
démarche du président de la république
eh bien je viens de prendre lecture
justement de cette lettre de mag ont
convaincu c'est ce serait beaucoup dire
qu'on soit convaincu il faut d'abord
étudier en détail ce qu'il propose en
tout cas il y a des choses qui ne vont
pas c'est vrai qu' il n'était pas autant
que l'ensemble des citoyens puissent
s'exprimer puisque dans cette lettre ils
parlent de démocratie et de citoyenneté
ils n'étaient pas autant que nous
puissions nous réunit est d'abord entré
lui mais aussi avec nos populations à
travers nos quartiers et aussi notre
grande messe pour bien approfondir tout
ce qui est proposé mais les réticences
sont d'ores et déjà nombreuses à depuis
hier depuis la les premiers éléments qui
ont fuité à propos de cette lettre c'est
de l'enfumage pour beaucoup peu de
chance que cela aboutisse à quelque
chose de concret pour d'autres et puis
l'organisation du débat vous êtes maire
du morne-rouge les maires que vous êtes
boudé par le président de la république
ne serait ce que lors du dernier congrès
des maires il vous est demandé de vous
impliquer dans ce débat ce que vous en
avez envie
madame 1 du dispostif il ne faut jamais
refusé des propositions c'est vrai que
l'ensemble des maires de la martinique
comme les maires de la france était très
en colère après le président de la
république mais il faut savoir que nous
avons un président qui a été élu par
nous faut le reconnaître nous avons fait
le choix de ce président avec un
programme qui avait été proposé dit ce
qu'il était on a voté pour lui parce
qu'il fallait barrer la route marine
open peut-être mais nous avons vu le
programme est aujourd'hui ce que je veux
dire c'est peut-être que healy a
peut-être d'expérience ou ce président
qui n'était pas un élu
il était plutôt technocrates mais c'est
vrai que ce qui fait mal aujourd'hui ce
sont les réformes qui sont peut-être
justifiée mais qui sont trop rapides et
aujourd'hui il est ce président je vais
pas défendre ce président mais je dois
souligner qu'il ya des réformes qui
aurait dû être fait depuis plusieurs
décennies par plusieurs présidents qui
l'ont précédé
aujourd'hui bien sûr il est aux
commandes
à lui d'assumer il a toute la
responsabilité de ce qui se fait et de
la mobilisation autour du gilet jaune
pour santé toujours de la sympathie pour
lui on se souvient qu on marche aurait
aimé vous voir candidate du parti lors
des dernières sénatoriales de toujours
une marche aux ingénieux du lys petit
écoutez je suis également celle sur le
sait le ce territoire payer mais puisque
je fais régulièrement démarche loquet
députés quand même puisque quand vous
vous promenez dans les couloirs de rue
dans les rues de votre commune dans les
quartiers des pélérins vous interpelle
puisque vous êtes là un élu de proximité
qu'est ce qui vous disent mes impôts ni
qu'est-ce qui vous interpelle vous savez
donc dès qu'on touche au porte monnaie
les gens réagissent donc nous comprenons
nous comprenons ces choses qui ne vont
pas c'est à dire que si son sens par
exemple mégots retraite et qu'il voit
quand encore il faut qu'on diminue sa
retraite donc ça fait très mal
nous comprenons ça nous aussi nous et
agissant parce que nous aussi nous
subissons oui mais ça reste toujours et
vos communes sont très sollicités et les
services sociaux sont très sollicités et
je tiens à féliciter justement le
personnel de service social qui est à l'
écoute 24 heures sur 24
bien les 130 ans les 50 ans du
morne-rouge le morne rouge devenue
commune en 1889 130 en tant que ville
150 ans en tant que paroisse si je crois
savoir que dans votre programme qui
s'étalera pendant toute l'année le 2
février ce sera une date
particulièrement importante pour vous
puisque on se souviendra démissionnaire
oui oui les gages aux missionnaires très
bien le 2 février est effectivement une
belle cérémonie à la
les volumes en rouge ou parler de cette
fondatrice j'avais calais martine est
quasiment unique et sache que la
congrégation des soeurs dominicaines
missionnaires de notre dame de la
délivrance est la seule qui a pris
naissance en martinique
de plus au monde rouge ce sont deux
filles de lotir de saint-pierre l'eau et
âme à sa baisse qui ont décidé de fonder
cette ode cet homme qui est qui s'est
répandue à travers le monde qu'ils
allaient en afrique au liban en egypte à
madagascar et c'était en suisse est bien
le 2 février justement nous allons avoir
une cérémonie passé qui lui assez bien
sûr la chandeleur
mais c'est également le retour de la
fondatrice parce qu'elle avait été
enterré à saint martin d'hères du côté
de grenoble et lan cyrulik vont revenir
et ce sera une cérémonie particulière
parce que c'est la première fois que
l'on vit rarement cynique que les
reliques seront à l'intérieur de
l'église
il n'y aurait pas eu cet épisode n'y
aurait pas eu de mort de rouge le monde
le rouge a toujours vécu autour de son
clocher
d'abord le clocher et ensuite le monde
roger des villes devenues communes
après abriter banlieue de saint pierre
appelez-vous les gens venaient au mont
rouge où se reposer et nous sommes
devenus commune par le décret de sadi
carnot qui était président de la
république en 1889
en même temps que la ville d'agen à
bouillon et la ville du marigot c'est
pourquoi nous sommes appelés les triplés
du nord alors dit mr vous en êtes la
première femme pour cette commune du
morne rouge alors mettra en avant
pendant toute cette année les
associations les infrastructures de la
commune vous mettre à l'honneur les
couples avec la plus grande longévité en
parlera de l'hymne de la commune il rend
les petits chanteurs à la coi à la croix
de bois
c'est une manifestation à la hauteur de
cet anniversaire ce seront des
manifestations à la hauteur de cet
anniversaire
oui j'ai entendu j'entends précisé à la
population martiniquaise que oui le
moment où jacent en 130 ans mais ça ne
veut pas dire que nous allons déroger à
ce que nous faisions traditionnellement
effectivement nous a redonné à chacune
de nos manifestations
une note d'anniversaire des centres
enfants d'abord vous venez le souligner
que le 2 février on en a parlé
ensuite nous aurons là
belle manifestation que nous faisons
tous les deux ans rassembler l'ensemble
des couples de plus de trente ans de
mariage et je j'ai plaisir à vous dire
que sous notre territoire il ya un
couple
pourquoi justement cet aspect des choses
je les cibles de plus de 30 ans le
couple a pu la transforme mariage parce
que l'idée nous est venue parce que en
parcourant les quartiers en discutant
avec les jambes sermon santé et qu'ils
avaient un besoin de rassemblement dans
ce domaine là il est important de
montrer que même si parfois les jeux ne
sont pas mariés mais les gens arrivent à
vivre bonne communauté et à élever
correctement leurs enfants donc c'est
pas des leçons de vie que nous allons
donner et montrer qu'on peut se
retrouver le vivre ensemble ça fait du
bien
donc un couple 64 années mariage un
couple de 66 ans de mariage
ce sont des exemples pour notre jeunesse
pour montrer que même si les temps
étaient difficiles et même si les temps
continuent à être difficile il y a des
moments on peut s'arrêter et partager
ensemble quelque chose de beau à un
moment où on renonce trop facilement
baisser les bras trop facilement où vont
les choses
kleenex comme on dit oui on a tendance à
banaliser mais pour montrer qu'il ya des
valeurs qui le maire alors les
infrastructures de la commune ont été
vains ont évolué vous avez un superbe
stadium vous avez une salle du millénium
y ait encore d'autres mais vous voulez
surtout mettre l'accent sur l'humain
envie de le voir avec cet hommage rendu
aux couples eux c'est vrai comme en
rouge c'est une commune sont équipés ou
là vous l'avez souligné
nous avons cet espace de comédiens puis
à petit sous laquelle se trouve cette
belle salle de spectacle que nous avons
voulu pour le lauréat man city nous ne
limitons pas cette salle sûrement au
pilier c'est vrai que nous avons cela
nous avons également le parcours santé
nous avons une salle de sport une petite
commune comme le monde roger nous avons
des espaces de quartier où les gens
peuvent aussi se rencontrer échanger
s'amuser et je disais que je voulais
justement l'homme soient mis davantage
en évidence
quels sont les enjeux aujourd'hui pour
cette ville du bord de rouge
quels sont les défis à relever mais le
grand défi pour nous aujourd'hui comme
dans toutes les communes c'est une autre
jeunesse notre jeunesse qui a besoin
d'accompagnement
le fonds jeunesse que
leur dis souvent m'en parler autant
l'aria ça me peine de voir des jeunes
qui traînent dans les rues aussi bien
les filles que les garçons
qu'est ce qu'on pouvait faire lorsque
vous assistez la raréfaction des moyens
financiers par exemple même si à part
les moyens financiers mais à
l'encadrement à mettre en place il ya
aussi l'écoutent et c'est ce que nous
faisons à travers les réunions de
quartier la démocratie participative est
très important c'est vrai que parfois on
dit que la jeunesse est turbulent mais
on trouve toujours du beau à travailler
quelqu'un on ne peut pas condamner où il
veut reprendre la main il faut
accueillir
il faut discuter et parfois vous avez
des surprises mais les associations qui
viennent vous dire madame le maire
banuta puisque l'agent parce que nous
viserons un new business a pour 104
exigent non chez nous les associations
ne disent pas qu'ils veulent plus
d'argent parce que nous avons un
fonctionnement particulier
c'est vrai que la plus grande
association de notre commune c'est le
gameplay nous finançons le club payait
nous lui donnons sa subvention annuelle
parce que nous savons que le gameplay à
plusieurs sections en athlétisme foot et
que ce sont de nombreux enfants qui sont
pris en charge par des bénévoles que je
tiens à remercier et à applaudir et un
travail formidable ce fait c'est vrai
que les associations ne demande pas de
subventions nous mettons à leur
disposition des locaux par
conventionnement est également nous leur
permettons justement le faire
elles-mêmes leurs subventions en métal
aux dispositions ne serait-ce que le
millénium pour organiser des soirées et
des dîners dansants des déjeuners
dansants et on voit qu'il ya beaucoup de
fougue et de passion dans votre dans vos
propos madame jenny dulys petit c'est
aussi parce que vous savez déjà que vous
serez candidate en 2020 vous l'avez dit
sur nos antennes semaine dernière oui je
serai candidate en 2020 parce que j'ai
été élu rappelez-vous en 2008 pour la
première fois par cette population
guinéenne que j'aime et je dois
souligner au passage que faire de la
politique c'est le savez pas dire que on
fait la politique pour faire la
politique si on n'aime pas les gens tu
n'aimes pas la commune on ne vient pas
aux élections
et moi comme j'aime la population
chilienne j'aime le monde ou rouge
donc je vais donner encore de mon temps
à cette population parce que je suis né
pour servir
merci beaucoup jenny dulys petit il
rappelle que vous êtes maire du mans de
rouge cette commune qui fête ses cent
trente ans d'existence merci bonne
journée
merci
[Musique]